so uh for those that don't know Elon
musk's text messages have been uh
released not all of them but many of
them I love this one and uh some of them
are like really silly like what is what
is this I jump on a grand for you like I
jump on a grand for you well this this
is what happens when someone's had an
iPhone and then they like your text
Android users see this ridiculous
message again I get it I'll say
something like you know like oh man I'm
feeling sick and it'll be like liked oh
man I'm feeling sick and I'm like thanks
for letting me know I guess but I'm like
Dad when you're just tapping it so uh
will what's what's going on here Elon
Musk is apparently gonna have to buy
Twitter what's the deal I mean yeah so
the litigation's ongoing remember that
Twitter sued Elon Musk to try and make
him buy the company and go through with
his merge with the merger agreement I
mean and I've predicted for quite some
time that Elon is going to lose this
lawsuit and he's gonna be forced by
Twitter uh the trial is coming up in a
couple weeks but anyway the reason we're
seeing all this stuff is because right
now they're in doing this like really
Rush Discovery process and everybody
he's producing everything including all
of elon's text messages with people that
relate in any way to the Twitter buyout
and so
some of these are absolutely hilarious
like there's a whole text conversation I
think I sent it to the group here's one
from um who is this
oh this is with Jason calacanas what's
going on with you marketing and spv2
randos this is not okay not randos I
have the largest Angel Syndicate that's
how I invest blah blah blah yeah so what
are some of the good ones oh the good
ones are one this one with Prague so
Prague I think I put this in the Twitter
group chat uh parag is the CEO of
Twitter yeah he says yeah proxy CEO
Twitter he says you are free to tweet
quote is Twitter dying end quote or
anything else about Twitter but it's my
responsibility to tell you that it's not
helping me make Twitter better in the
current context next time we speak I'd
like to provide you with perspective on
the internal distraction how it's
causing it blah blah blah Elon response
what did you get done this week I'm not
joining the board this is a waste of
time we'll make an offer to take Twitter
private also this is why I like Elon and
yeah zero to 100. imagine imagine
talking to someone like paraga yeah like
that the way he talked it's just I'd be
like come on guys say words let's let's
figure out what you need to get done
that you don't like there's two typos in
in perox response I'd like to you
provide you perspective and then on the
level of internal distraction right now
and how it hurting our ability to do
work like he's the CEO of Twitter and he
gets two typos in a message to Elon Musk
who wants to spend 54 billion dollars
but a guy can't get his his his text
right like right dude
I would I would be also be very annoyed
if I got a text like that from someone
that was purported to be a CEO yeah well
check your text yeah I think I mean it
does show that sort of the decision to
take go and take Twitter private was a
little bit emotional on like elon's part
and kind of impulsive yeah he probably
regretted it on yeah he probably and I
think that's I mean that's the heart of
a lawsuit is that you know you just have
buyer's remorse like you you suddenly
realize value tanked you know well not
that the value tank but he thought he
saw a General market downturn coming and
the the amount of money that it was
going to take to buy Twitter was just
too big a portion of his net worth and
would have too many implications on
Tesla and and SpaceX yeah that and
Twitter's you know trash
yeah but I don't know I think I mean
that was never why Elon really wanted to
buy it I don't think I mean he always
said it wasn't an economic rationale and
I I heard that I I think that I I got a
question what is what does Elon care
about his net worth you know I I mean it
I mean I understand wanting to build
stuff but I mean it implicates his
ability to continue to control what
happens at Tesla for example because
most of his net worth is bound up in
Tesla stock so I guess it would take too
much of his stock right so we'd have to
sell too much of it the value would go
down his his overall control of Tesla
might decrease I'm not exactly sure if
Tesla operates with the you know Class A
Class B shares that always means that he
is this is a question you know here's a
question right you know I've spent a
long time working on this this YouTube
channel as long as as well as many other
people and my other show uh podcast on
my other YouTube channels and it's like
would I sacrifice these if it meant I
got to own Twitter
and then shut Twitter down
and I'm kind of like I mean I could be I
think ultimately Twitter's going to be a
better business than Tesla frankly well
Tesla's working on a lot of things like
personalized robots I don't know if you
heard about this one they might be but
I'm still I mean I their basic business
is is car manufacturing and and car
manufacturing is a terrible business
it's just super Capital intensive I mean
every other car manufacturer in the
World trades at like a price to earnings
ratio of six or something which is just
way below and the government's not
giving him any subsidies they're giving
it to a lot of other yeah so uh it's
just it's just I think you know being an
auto manufacturer is actually a really
rough and hard business there's a reason
Tesla was like a few years ago was like
nearly going bankrupt and why a lot of
the big manufacturers go to Mexico or
China oh yeah and I mean think about all
the constant bankruptcies you hear about
GM and Ford and I mean it's super
competitive too that's the other thing I
mean elon's not the only guy making
electric cars there's a billion other
manufacturers coming out with them
so I look at Twitter Twitter's kind of
got this almost Monopoly on this
particular type of Public Square
communication it's just a question of
how to monetize it but you know compare
like all the Twitter competitors are
getting wrecked it's not the same in car
manufacturers where there's a lot of
effective competition Mize doesn't have
a lot of overhead which is a big upside
like Twitter's got I don't know 5 000
employees sure yeah ridiculous amount of
money you spend on that I don't even
know what they're doing but it's
fireable but like I mean think about
what happened to parlor right like
parlor I don't know if you saw there was
actually a small news item but the new
Power CEO basically said they're they're
pivoting away from their legacy social
media business into like servers for the
you know trying to can you know similar
to rumble create like the uncancelable
economy
um gabs is getting wrecked right and so
the idea is that the you know cloud
services yeah so they're I mean
basically that's that's the CEO of
parlor or the new CEO parlor looking at
it and like wow this social media
business is not going anywhere I'm going
to do something else uh Jason is he
still the CEO the news CEO the new seat
no Jason left I think it's it's Candace
Owens husband is the news no of parlors
George farmer yeah parlor and getter and
gab and it's like oh yeah get her get
her I mean getter's just funded by the
Chinese like billionaire the guy who
funds Bannon guo I thought he was
bankrupt I don't think he's bankrupt but
that's where the like the original
funding yeah Jason Miller of getter is
what I was talking about and he's still
CEO see that's the thing I got parlor
and get her mixed up like they're both
ER Twitter get her parlor like they're
just copying carbon like and what's the
difference here
no it's no e just the consonant and then
the r the only way they're trying to
compete like their entire competitive
Advantage is we don't censor but that's
not really a competitive Advantage like
they're proud I mean and the end result
of that is I mean if if you're you get
the the core of your user base then
becomes the people who were censored I
don't even know why people use Twitter I
don't know I mean I like I like Twitter
and Twitter's where everybody else is so
it's still the functional Public Square
I think yeah this is one of those
Twitter and this particular type of
social media business is just it's a
natural monopoly Elon he needs to buy it
man yeah because he's so much better we
need we need Alex Jones back we need
Carl Benjamin back we need milianopoulos
back we need Laura Loomer back should be
on there they should be saying what they
think and being they should be allowed
yeah I mean just settle dude you're
gonna lose anyway I don't think you're
going to lose this lawsuit settled by
the company maybe that's the ideas
he's going to get it cheaper now just by
forcing a settlement maybe but we're I
mean we're you know he's close we're
close to a trial in an order from the
judge that says yeah Elon you're you you
are ordered to buy the company at this
price wow that's cool what if he can't
he has the money like and everybody
knows he has that I mean that you can do
public based on his public Holdings of
you know Tesla can they force
liquidation of Tesla oh yeah
yeah wow and hold him in contemption
well basically they can hold him in
contempt until he does it and charge it
and is find him enough money that
effectively enforces it yeah I think I
think you said this before that uh a
judge can hold you in contempt in a way
that's that's reasonable to make you
comply right like if you're very wealthy
they will just make it painful for you
right there there's there's no limit to
the amount they can find you if if
you're just in content flouting in a
court order right they're they're going
to do as much as is necessary to get you
to comply did you guys see the Jack
Dorsey Elon Musk texts are those also
from Discovery yeah yeah it's like I
have it all here but there's like no way
I'm gonna be able to go through it yeah
there's better formats I've seen of it
CNBC did a story on it Jack Dorsey tried
to get Eli but it's them talking about
basically that they want to they both
want to decentralize the the technology
and uh work together and the Jack was
like I couldn't I could try and get you
on the board I got three percent of the
company and really no pull there but
I'll see what I can do and then he's
like what I really want to do is use
this stuff as a decentralized protocol
anyone's like okay I like that idea so
if he buys Twitter uses the software
freeze the software code makes it like a
universal Global effort to create a
decentralized encrypts private messages
to anyone well the downside of encrypted
messages if I send you something
encrypted you can send that to anyone I
don't have any like I gotta you gotta
trust the person on the other end but
the idea is it's encrypted between the
two people yeah that are using the
message yeah yeah
encrypted messaging is key so how do you
think this is going to play out how do
you see this kind of going forward
what's the timeline and then uh do you
see a a big kind of blowback if Elon
does take over that there might be some
efforts because Bill Gates already had a
lot of secretive efforts with his uh
organizations trying to of course attack
Elon Musk they had a big public beef he
used a lot of his ngos as a form to
attack him will there be attacks on
Twitter to of course compromise it as a
platform I mean I don't know if they can
really compromise it as a platform I
think you'll see the activists will be
in a different position where because
Elon won't pay attention to the
left-wing activists in the same way that
the current management does what I'm
speculating is what if someone says okay
well Elon has the platform now let's
talk about how many Bots are on the
platform oh it's it's 50 of the platform
but it's a private company so it's not
subject to the same sort of security
regulation but someone could leak or or
try to of course sabotage the company
yeah I mean maybe but it's it the the
the sort of obvious methods of sabotage
that you're thinking of wouldn't work in
the world where it's a private company
and then it doesn't have to obey
Securities laws in the same way right
where it's you know the it's it's one of
the big disciplining things about our
system and and I think people you know
we think that the free market and
capitalism only you know works because
of competition but one big thing is that
public company CEOs have to tell the
truth about their companies every three
months in a way that politicians don't
yeah you know politicians can just lie
and lie and lie about the operation of
the government and so can the department
heads and nobody goes nobody's ever you
know threatened to jail for that but if
you are a public company CEO and you lie
about your business results you can go
to jail for Securities fraud but why
don't we make it so that whenever you're
inaugurated or whatever you swear uh
enough to to you know tell the truth
well it's like it's it's like the
government the problem is it's the
government trying to hold itself
accountable for honesty and especially
like the highest level officials and it
just doesn't it doesn't work the same
way the reason this works is because the
sovereign is imposing that discipline on
on public company CEOs I I remember uh
James Clapper testifying on her oath
that they weren't wittingly spying on
the American people with the prism
software or the prism program and they
were but I mean in the user use the word
wittingly like maybe they were
inadvertently doing it and didn't
realize it but I mean I think they were
kind of wittingly spying and like no
there was no yeah you know there's these
external consequences right like even
James Clapper should have been
prosecuted but I mean you can't the
intelligence agencies have the own their
own problem which is like the the
ultimately the J Edgar Hoover problem
they know too much yeah lying to
Congress you know that's a charge that's
being thrown around right now Hoover did
that routinely exactly
but you know individuals like Roger
Roger Stone get charged for that other
individuals like the former head of the
CIA that knowingly lie that also get us
into Wars no no no it's weird that one
it's like the the industrial agriculture
of politics is like or what do you call
it when they have a bunch of like Pig
slaughterhouses in secret we don't want
to look at it we don't want to smell it
but we we know those pigs are getting
cut up in like tens by tens of thousands
people are grabbing piglets and smashing
them on the ground because they don't
like them like crazy people working
these Slaughter shops we know it's
happening a lot of people do but we're
just letting it happen because we want
that bacon we know the CIA is lying but
we just let it happen because it's the
we need a Secret Agency telling lies for
a living like that's the whole point of
the CIA I don't know if you can prepare
the ca to bacon you know bacon has a
purpose
bacon actually helps people I have bacon
every morning and it may it like it's
the light of my day I'll tell you more
about it I just started the CIA book and
I'm going to read more about it what is
it called it's called let me see a
legacy of Ashes
sounds about right yeah which is really
I mean I think is that from the JFK
quote I'm not sure JFK had a famous
quote about what he wanted to do with
the CIA oh yeah yeah yeah and um
it was like I'll tell you what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna tear them up set him on
fire and then piss on them there's a
really great xcia uh former CIA
counter-terrorist expert Kevin Shipp and
I highly recommend looking up anything
he does on the internet he he wrote a
book called from the company of Shadows
talking about CA operations abuse of
secrecy and he's like full out they
threatened his family he said since he's
left and talked about it but he's like
just straight up and telling you there's
like a law they have that lets them lie
it almost encourages for the name of
National Defense standard protocol what
was uh Mike pompeo's uh he said you know
we were taught to lie cheat and steal
and that's exactly what we did some he
said something to to that tone I forgot
what it was I gotta pull it up
yeah I've just I also finished Tim same
guy Tim weiner wrote a book called uh
enemies which was about the FBI that's
also a really good book I've sort of you
know read about the FBI and CA since
we're all talking about fixing him
um fixing yeah right dismantling
um but yeah no CIA see the big thesis of
CI the CIA book so far is the CIA is
actually incompetent like we think of it
as scary and over you know abusive but
in real you know the big lesson is more
than anything it was just straight up
incompetent and killed a lot of its own
agents for no good reason well I would
argue that's a cover but that's just my
own pure speculations but Mike Pompeo
did say on the record quote we lied we
cheated we stole we had entire training
courses it reminds you of the glory of
the American experiment that's literally
what he said
um and now he might be running uh to be
the next president of the United States
the glory of the American experiment
meaning like stealing the land from the
native population
Ah that's you know like telling them you
know we're gonna we're gonna make a deal
with you and then not giving them this
stuff I mean there's a well I think it
was those the natives would would give
their land for like blankets and then
they wanted the land back and they're
like no you call that they call it
Indian giver it was like this real
offensive you know I'm not they still
call them Indian like they're from India
I'm not an expert in Indian history but
I know there's a lot of contention to
what actually happened Indian history is
in India the Native American population
that was abuse of slander to call those
people Indians especially if they knew
they didn't land in India and they knew
that really early on I think actually a
lot of them don't care well I care but
you call Indians Indian call Native
Americans Americans thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there